let me ask you about what happened with
lee zeldin
so you have this guy with uh cat ears
you know i wouldn't call it uh
people are referring to as a bladed
weapon is that fair to say do you think
would you so it's a self-defense device
but i mean it it is you know it would if
if he had hit his
you know
neck or artery or something he could
have bled out i mean there's there's no
doubt this is a very dangerous
situation um i you see this stuff and it
happened what a couple months
a couple months ago we just saw some guy
try to assassinate kavanaugh or at least
made great strides to get to that point
yeah no i mean again i i think i think
this this you know
culture of violence that we have right
now uh and it's you know it's very broad
um but you know the political violence i
mean it's just incredibly dangerous is
this and it's you know is it is it you
know we talked about earlier is it is it
gonna be worth doing these jobs you know
even being a public figure i mean it's
just it's not
um it will be if you're a communist
if you're if you're in a cult or you're
ideologically driven like i just
mentioned this guy he's wearing the
black lives matter mask at taco bell and
he says fire me i'm not taking it off
he's willing to throw himself you know
on top of the of the issue because he
he'll sacrifice his position to wear
that mask and they give it to him
because of it and so you look at now
what's going on with
uh the violence you've got people on the
left who are willing to destroy their
careers or get paid almost nothing to be
in that position and the right's
unwilling to do it they're saying things
like you know what it's easier and more
comfortable just to get out of here and
do something else and that's why they
lose so now you see this guy who
attacked zeldin and he says
he i guess the latest reports that he
didn't know who zeldin was or whatever
okay yeah i don't think you go to a
political rally the day after the day uh
the governor puts out a statement about
the guy getting up on stage holding a
weapon and then trying to tell him he's
done and then moving gesturing i'm being
very careful here towards his neck with
it whether it's for the microphone his
neck whatever
i don't i don't think you just do that
randomly but these are people who when
when you get someone who's willing to
sacrifice their their livelihood and
their job or their own safety these are
people who are willing to wear all black
and firebomb federal buildings
uh
i
i gotta tell you man this is
asymmetrical uh culture war where the
right is like we're gonna win when
regular people wake up to the gas prices
and it's like yeah i think
that's that's that's potentially true a
lot of people working class families are
going to be looking at the five dollars
a gallon gas in the fort it's 4 and 30
cents average right now and they're
going to be very angry about it but how
many people are indoctrinated and don't
care about gas at all how many posts
have you seen on facebook where people
say
i don't care about high gas prices
january 6 is more important because i
see those all the time i see people who
are facebook friends well i've got
thousands of people on facebook that
cleanse that list of crazy people even
biden said it's worth it so we could
stick take a stand for ukraine we did
the right thing
republicans
they were up before that even happened
don't want to sacrifice
anything
and the left will sacrifice them well
they don't want to sacrifice they have a
lot to say i mean
you know
a lot of republicans are very successful
or and have you know have ambition i
mean they have goals and desires and you
know i want to accomplish things not
only for themselves but for their family
and they want their family to be
successful so i i mean i hear what
you're saying
you know
there's there's so many of these people
especially people uh many many
republicans retiring they don't want to
be involved in it at all so they're like
i'm going to retire yeah because it's
not worth the money maybe you made
enough money it is it would be so easy
for so many of these people you don't
need that much money to retire forever
and so what i see is what is the number
to retire forever yeah i mean let's just
look at the average retirement if you
wanted to be a regular person and you
retire on half a million to a million
now most of these people in congress i
think what is like half of them are
millionaires or some ridiculous number
so it wouldn't surprise me i mean their
retirement benefits are also very good
right nancy pelosi's net worth is 135
million she could leave at any moment
she never has to work a day in her life
you just got two fridges full of ice
cream by the way really expensive ice
cream too yeah these are people who just
want power yeah she she made a video
during the pandemic like people were
hurting and broke and she's like look at
my fifty dollar i tried that's very good
and everybody was like thanks so
disgusting
oh yeah that's nancy pelosi for you she
should return what's even more
disgusting is tim doing nancy pelosi i
tried even worse
that's how she talks
sides of the back your tongue smacking
on your inner cheek the the way i see it
man is um
i get it
i get it yeah you know look we we here
at tim cast we're we're successful
you know so we're here it would be so
easy for me i wish my podcast was
successful we've got a bunch of new
shows we're launching and and um i'm
gonna break down for everybody why we do
what we do i think i mentioned this last
week timcast.com what was the first show
that we launched it was tales from the
inverted world true crime mystery
history podcast why they're very popular
particularly among women we already have
a political podcast where we talk ad
nauseum about all of these issues then
we launched pop culture crisis with bret
uh dasivec we brought on mary morgan to
co-host it because that's not political
because the goal for the website isn't
just to
argue with people and say hey that thing
they're doing on tv is dumb and that
thing that they said in congress was
stupid it's like we got to change
culture we got to change it all but
here's the crazy thing it is
people don't i don't think people
understand how difficult it is to do all
of this how much time it takes
16 hours a day plus you know several
hours on the weekends every waking
moment of my life on the phone answering
emails and i got to figure out which
emails to answer to make all of this
work and it would be so incredibly easy
to cut everything down do a single show
and just be well off and say why am i
risking my neck and stressing myself out
for people who won't do the same
because i genuinely believe that there
are a lot of people who listen who do
want to do that and so maybe there are a
lot of people who are like you know
those all that cult stuff is really bad
but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna get
involved great well i'm not talking to
them i guess maybe i'm trying to
encourage them to stand up and change
the world but i think there are a lot of
people who are like
i'm ready i'm willing and i'm gonna
speak up and i'm gonna make a difference
and i'm like well then we gotta have a
space that allows for that to happen and
we got to encourage more and more people
to get involved so i'm i'm more content
doing that
as opposed to so many other people who
you know they're
i don't want to be in government because
it's not worth the pay and then the
democrats try to destroy you and then
you look at what they put brett
kavanaugh through so there are certainly
a lot of people who are standing up who
are pushing back and doing the right
thing and i can respect them and i think
we got to get more people to do it but
the way i see it with what we're doing
at tim cast is at the very least we're
just going to create a cultural space to
the best of our abilities we're going to
fight for it every day
to not just be overtly political because
one thing the right does and they they
do terribly is they argue about what the
left does instead of doing things they
say hollywood made a movie the movie
sucks okay well now you got the daily
wire making their own movies timcast.com
we're starting to launch our own shows
that's the path
we create shows we create culture and we
create a new place for people to go to
get away from the influence of the
democrats and their psychotic cult
that i think is the path towards
changing things it is the hardest path
possibly to take so
i totally get it why there are so many
people who are like i make good money
why speak up yeah and in the in the
frightening thing i'm sure for you all
and i'm sure you know the reason you're
trying to get more at on your website
is because of how easy it is for big
tech to de-platform you
oh hands down i mean it's just it's it's
because you know there there are
ways to monetize these types of things
that are you know that are pretty good
when you're on these platforms but they
can take it away tomorrow and that's i
mean that that's that's what anybody
that wants to create a show or content
or or do anything i mean you don't do
obviously you don't do it for the money
but like that
i think that's a reward for being good
it's and it's not just about uh like
getting banned it's about the
manipulation the shadow banning yeah so
you know we we had a show called cast
castle which was like a vlog and we did
bits and then we ramped up the joke
because honestly just it's fun to write
jokes and act
um and then the issue is we can't do a
lot of jokes you get banned for it or
you could build your business up on
their platform they don't ban you they
just cut your money off yeah after a
decade of investment and then your
show's gone and it's like okay
why build up their platform we'll build
up ours and so now you know this show is
live on the front page of timcast.com
we're doing a lot we've done
infrastructure we've kicked paypal off
the website
paypal and their sensorius attitudes and
silicon valley cultism we now use
parallel economy which is co-founded by
dan bongino and is censorship resistant
so my view is hopefully in five years
the big pop culture conversation is oh
yeah that new movie that just came out
on timcast.com and we're we're not going
to be overtly political we don't make
conservative content we're not
conservatives just make content then
it's not woke and we'll create a space
to call out the lies the democrats have
been pushing and look i don't like the
uniparty republicans either but the
democrats are the ones who control the
cultural institutions that are burning
everything down
you're right you're right
that's what we do i guess good i love it
that's why i'm here
yeah i've heard good things well i'm i'm
optimistic in that regard but i also
kind of feel like we're building an arc
in a sense like it's going to get way
worse than it is now a lot of people
think that's pessimistic i'm like i
don't look at it negatively you know i
just look at i think i look at it like
mathematically
what's happening now culturally
culturally and politically is
negative points towards the united
states it's getting worse it's getting
worse
that doesn't mean everyone's going to
die and the sun's going to burn out and
the planet's going to no there's still a
roam there's still a rome there's no
roman empire well
i mean that's just like that it turned
into a church the roman catholic church
now
it's another kind of mental control they
couldn't do it militarily it was too big
it splintered so they just want to keep
it keep that influence yeah and i think
you know
my friend rick grinnell says often you
know most uh great civilizations have
lasted about 250 years we're what 246
right now we're there yeah and so we we
have the the people of the united states
are going to have to decide and uh i
think there are a lot of headwinds in
that regard i also think
you know we're the greatest idea ever
conceived in human history right so
we'll see if we can you know as a people
figure it out yeah i don't think it's
going to be through legislation i don't
think we can legislate solution or print
solutions within the federal reserve
it's it's industry like actually making
things like graphene
like it's obsessive we've been talking
about the last two years to bring
awareness we have been obsessively
talking about i thought i have i have
been but i don't even are you familiar
with the material it's now graphing time
oh oh uh check this out check this out
you know it's ian's credit i got an ad
for an electric bike its range was 150
miles
that blew my mind yeah because we've got
some electric bikes the range is like 40
or 50 miles and it charges in 15 minutes
it's incredible 15 minutes so this is a
battery compound it's a pure carbon it's
just carbon and it's hexagonally lattice
like a honeycomb flat one layer atomic
thick
it's electrically conductive
capacitative like a battery it's super
you can super conduct my point the bike
uses a graphene battery dude and it's
you can pull carbon dioxide out of the
air put it on condense it onto palladium
and then turn it into graphene so we can
basically mine the air mine the carbon
out of the air we can mine the methane
out of the air and we're gonna be end up
competing with trees so if we we just
need to renegotiate and bring awareness
to the government i think to teach them
about the 21st century industry well
isn't this the point i was trying to
make earlier and obviously you do it
better with like a real technology but
it's but human innovation is you know
going
because that doesn't that solve the
excess carbon in the environment if
we're competing with trees trees are the
ones that are pulling out carbon dioxide
but this is what we're running into
because because yes right we get carbon
in the air and then like ian says we
mine the air for carbon and we need more
of it we can't take too much you run
into people who post things memes like
elon musk is wasting money going to
outer space that money should be spent
here in the in the united states and
it's like where do you think they spent
the money do you think that elon went to
the moon and gave moon people our money
no he hired american workers to work on
american products to machine american
parts to make an american spaceship it
goes up into space and then it comes
back
these people don't understand when we
talk about new technologies you are up
against ideology versus innovation and
the ideologues are saying there's too
much carbon therefore
shut everything down
take away people's fuel let the
diabetics die when the refrigerators
stop working they don't have insulin
anymore and that will solve the problem
and then you have the innovators saying
can we i don't know mine carbon from the
air to reduce the parts per million so
that we can offset global warming but
then also use it for something
innovative no they don't give you the
chance
there are people who oppose human
ingenuity and people who support it and
right now the democratic party what are
we watching right now joe biden's
selling off 20 million barrels of the
strategic petroleum reserve a decent
amount goes to china they say the reason
is because china it legally has to go to
the highest bidder so europe and then
china they get it and my question is joe
biden if if if he comes which makes no
sense i want to just
hang a lantern on what you just said
which is true but it makes no sense it's
the united states strategic patrol right
reserve
it's not supposed to be sold off it's
supposed to be used not to be but
they're trying yeah they're trying to
lower the prices so the question is
you know if joe biden
comes out and says he's going to get us
off fossil fuels
and then you see i think jeremy what
they shut down their nuclear plants
right is that what happened i believe so
yes i think so you i don't know you want
to fact check that
they did
i'm wondering then you know they're not
greta tunberg says we don't want to wait
until 2030 we want to stop fossil fuels
now and it's like
it just sounds like they want to kill
people that that's all it sounds like
that we've got a food shortage coming in
and say stop farming we've got a fuel
crisis and they're saying sell it off
and shut down our power plants and i'm
like you're just trying to get rid of
humans bill gates wrote four years ago
we have to stop poverty in africa
because they're having too many kids so
there'll be more poor people and i'm
like
so you're not saying kill them you're
saying don't let them exist in the first
place
it sounds an awful lot like they're just
nuking the system on price i think a lot
of it is ignorance like maybe there are
some destructive people that want to
wipe out a segment of the population
just for whatever short-sighted
desire but the people that want to
create less carbon don't seem to
understand that we can pull it out of
the atmosphere pretty readily well
that's the point ideology versus
innovation how do you convince a zombie
horde screaming the end is nigh that
there are ways to solve these problems
to technology you can't thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you